one of the things that I get all excited
about but I'll never be able to resolve
intellectually is the origin of slavery
we know that slavery is prehistoric and
we and we set you know we can say that
because the very first stylus on clay
tablet cuneiform records of ancient
Sumeria which are the very first human
records are records of slavery the price
of slaves counts of slaves how they were
acquired through conflict and so forth
so clearly it was not just existing
before the first written records it was
existing in a fairly sophisticated way
so there is a question in my mind that I
happened I'll never be able to resolve
but I find it a wonderful intellectual
challenges thing how does any human
being come to the point where they can
completely control another person use
violence and use use that violence to
exploit people you know how did that
evolve in the prehistory of human human
societies in their most primitives if we
still use that word but their earliest
forms there seems to be a kind of
familial model the idea that you know
the way that you can control offspring
can sometimes be total and violent
control and be exploitative as well I
mean we don't want to do that these days
with our middle-class kids but you know
you look back and you see that it it
also seems then as you look at
prehistory and early history and I mean
really early history Iron Age stuff you
you begin that period of the
domestication of animals and the and
that the nature of enslavement begins to
shift from what I would think to be a
familial model a family model to an
animal domestication model so that you
actually get to the point where
Aristotle writes the Ox is the poor
man's slave in other words he's equating
the ox and a slave and saying you know
if you if you can afford it you'll buy a
human but if you can't afford it you'll
end up dying in hawks which is kind of
interesting because oxen were also very
expensive now what does that mean well
it means it's also slavery is also pre
legal you know the code of hammurabi the
famous one that we study at university
because the first written legal code
if you actually read that straight
through what you discover is about
thirty percent of the Code of Hammurabi
is about slavery which tells us that it
was a highly sophisticated part of that
society before they even wrote the laws
down so it was pre legal in a
sophisticated way and had to be included
in that it's also pre monetary so that
when we have those moments where we see
here's the invention of money we
discover that they come after the
records of enslavement so pre monetary
pre legal prehistoric it's a fascinating
question in my mind like how to slavery
even begin and then what does it evolve
into its there's never been a day in
human history without it it doesn't is
not in every society however and that's
also kind of important because it's not
a integral inherent part of the human
existence you know there are plenty of
societies that have existed for
thousands of years with no slavery
whatsoever and there's a course that
part in all of us as individuals that
says I don't enslave anybody but even
more importantly I don't ever want to be
in select so it's not like we're born to
slavery and yet it's been this kind of
semi permanent condition and it's
evolved to respond to almost every type
of economic and political change that's
occurred in 5,000 years so you see a an
empire like the Roman Empire it runs on
slavery the way America runs on oil you
know the all the wars of conquest of the
expansion of the Roman Empire were
fueled exactly by conquest of
geographical areas and the harvesting of
entire populations to the slave markets
of Rome were two other main cities that
would then bankroll the payment of the
legions and the armies and so forth and
you see this interesting expansion and
contraction of slavery linked to almost
all imperial growth the Ottoman Empire
and then the European empires of the
18th and 19th century they don't instead
of taking over it all physically and
making it all colonies but it's all
about the harvesting of the slaves for
North America until you even get into
the modern late 20th century early 21st
and you have this
new globalization form of empire
building where you don't take physical
possession of the land but you'd still
take physical position of the people at
least temporarily as inputs into just in
time economic processes so anything that
we've been able to think of as human
beings clever or evil in terms of
economic exploitation somebody's always
been able to figure out a way to build
slavery into that as well